So, coming back to our atomic instructions, we have
seen that we can have an atomic exchange, where the
problem was that it keeps writing to the lockvar even
when it's not available. Our test and write class of
instructions, is trying to avoid that. By testing the
memory location, and only writing to it if they find
a zero there. And we might implement a log, with
a test and store, for example, instruction, we will implement
a log by setting R1 to 1, then testing log
variance storing R1 there. And the result we get from this
test and store, let's say 0 in R1 means that
the lockvar was occupied. In which case, we will just repeat
this, try this again and again. But the idea is
that, as long as the lock is occupied, this test and
store is only reading the lock variable, it is not writing
to it. This is good, because remember coherence. If you keep
writing, you keep invalidating all the other copies. So,
everybody that is waiting, keeps generating bus traffic because
they're all trying to write, and thus invalidating each
other. In contrast the test and store, everybody that is
waiting while the lock is occupied, simply gets to
share the lock variable. They are all having it in
the shared state and simply ro, and simply iterating
on their cached copy. Once the lock has been freed,
those shared copies are invalidated, because the unlock, writes
to the lock variable. At this point, everybody sees
the new value and tries to grab the lock,
so there's really only communication on the lock, when the
lock becomes free, until somebody acquires it again. So
this test and write approach, solves the problem of
continuously writing to the lock variable, but doesn't really
solve the problem of, this is a really strange instruction.
It's neither a store nor a load. It
would be ideal for processor design, if we could
do something that is very much like a load,
and very much like a store, yet behaves this
way. And that brings us to the third
type of atomic instructions, which are really now two
instructions. The special load, and a special store, that
are somehow linked together, to create an atomic instruction.